what when was the first time you heard
about West Side Story and how did you
get involved with the production of the
film well we we we joined United Artists
under an arrangement where we would
produce films for them and we
fortunately we we made a few pictures
that I am also very proud of prior to
making West Side Story the first of
which was in the Magnificent Seven which
you you may recall and after that some
like it hot which you will also recall
some what I'm during that period I was
in New York with my wife we decided we
were going to go to the theater and see
a show and we chose West Side Story and
it it just knocked me out it one of the
most extraordinary musicals I had ever
seen on a stage and and I said oh my god
wouldn't it be exciting to make a film
of that and then a long complicated
process began and finally we we were
able to corral the rights to it and well
you'll see the result of it here
this sounds good so I just want to
remind everybody that when this film
came out the the blacklist was your when
that was being made the blacklist was
still alive in Hollywood and the civil
rights movement was just getting started
I mean this was really a very
aggressively modern take on race
relations in America and also to take
the well that was one of the what are
the principal things that that
recommended it to me I thought this was
a an extraordinary opportunity to say
something about racial relations in
America
mm-hm and to say it in a way that would
bring audiences to see it and and
perhaps benefit from the lesson of West
Side Story mm-hmm I as you see it now
and and connect it with the what what's
happening every week now it it is more
topical I think even than it was at that
time and I my efforts in this direction
which also included my film in the heat
of the night which
which I hope would also reach people
with a a certain understanding of the
possibilities of the necessity for the
races to come together and and stop this
senseless warfare it is discouraging
that that lesson has still not been
learned and I hope others will take up
the cudgels and continue to fight that
battle